alrighty folks so we are going to be
examining the new trailer for spider-man
no way home as you can tell i'm ecstatic
to be back in the marvel universe it's
what i love best
oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females
stop come on yes my spider lord that's
not good dialogue can we just like stay
up here all day it is so crazy down
there
fast cut
spiderman is in fact peter parker listen
i did not kill mysterio the drones did
the drones that are yours
does any part of you feel relieved about
all this what do you mean
now that everybody knows you don't
really have to hide or lie to people for
the record i never wanted to lie to you
but how do you tell someone that you're
spider-man you say i'm spider-man
typically
now everybody knows
but this isn't about me this is hurting
a lot of people
i've just been thinking about how to fix
all of this
okay
oh he's gonna go doctor strange's house
why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry to
bother you sir please his hanging out is
so weird doctor strange i think we're
beyond you colonies i'm not sure why he
just hangs out that way
that feels weird but i'll allow it
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up
i was wondering if maybe you could make
it so that he never did
strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
fine
i won't okay i like his mug did you see
his mug his mug is funny did you see the
monkeys carrying there it says oh for
fox sake that is what the mug says
the entire world is about to forget that
peter parker is spider-man wait everyone
can't some people still know that's not
how the spell works
so mj's gonna forget about everything
we've ever been through stop tampering
with this you can just go to her house
and tell her ned he's my best house and
tell him
uh oh you did a bad spell
what just happened bad stuff bad stuff
happened peter
we tampered with the stability of space
time oh from inception multiverse is a
concept about which we know oh so we're
just gonna do inception now
oh and now we're gonna do the scene from
solo with the with the train robbery
trying to live two different lives
oh cause that's from the first doctor
strange dangerous it becomes
oh the green goblin's here
is it willing to fall be careful what
you wish for parker
hello oh it's alfred molina he looks
older
all right
okay so that stars tom holland and uh
i've been informed that it's pronounced
zendaya and um
honestly the only thing about this that
i find even remotely interesting is
alfred molina showing up at the end
that's pretty much the only thing
although didn't he die in the tobey
maguire spider-man so is this now it's
an alternative universe or did toby
mcguire never play poker and that's
actually toby mcguire but he looks
really young i'm confused the old
spider-man world never happened right i
mean my understanding is that this was
re-launched this is an entirely
different universe hawaii but but we're
supposed to remember that alfred molina
is doc ock but we're not supposed to
remember that peter parker was toby
mcguire he no longer exists after cider
house rules
that's a little confusing um also isn't
that like a green goblin bomb that we
see there right like that that's thrown
on there it's like the green goblin says
willem dafoe going to show up as well
because i'm up for that i'm like a
little up for william defoe he looks
exactly the same william defoe is he's
like
paul rudd but bad looking right like
paul rudd has been 25 for the last 30
years and willem dafoe has been 65 for
the last 40 years
so i i guess i guess he could do that
alfred molina kind of looks the same
looks like he's lost a little weight
actually since his original doc ock days
also is the idea of doctor strange
supposed to be that he's incompetent so
here's one of my big problems with all
of these universes the basic premise is
that people should be good at their jobs
right they i get very ticked off at
movies or tv shows where the people's
chief problem is that they are very bad
at their jobs and so there was a tv show
called tehran which was supposed to be
kind of a knock off of 24 and then there
was an israeli show called fought it was
kind of a knockoff of those and the spy
was like an israeli female spy from
assad except she's terrible at
everything she's the worst person like
you would fire her in in a heartbeat if
she were actually this bad at her job
and i get that feeling from doctor
strange in this trailer like it doesn't
seem like that big like where's the men
in black device and also why can't he
why is peter so freaked out in that
trailer about mj and his aunt and his
best friend not knowing he still has a
mouth and a brain connected to that face
couldn't he just like leave directly
from doctor strange's and go directly to
their houses and be like by the way i'm
spider-man wouldn't that solve like all
the problems immediately i don't mean to
short-circuit the entire plot of the
film but
that's kind of weird also that is a
really bad excuse for rewriting the
entire nature of reality is because
you're having a tough time that people
know who you are i guess at the end of
the last movie mysterio revealed that
peter parker is in fact spider-man and
so this is giving peter parker trouble
in his teenage life and so we are now
going to rewrite all of reality to avoid
his
teenage
problems can be whatever i want i'll be
honest i am up i am a little bit up for
the doctor strange replacing iron man as
as peter parker's surrogate father
figure like i'm kind of up for that they
killed off iron man for no reason in the
last avenger like it was for a reason
but the only reason was the only way
they can make you care about any of
those characters is to kill off like one
of the three people you actually care
about so they just killed off robert
downey jr for no reason at the end of it
like it didn't make any sense in the
plot they killed him off so that you
could have a sad moment and then you
were mostly like well that wasn't as sad
as i thought it was going to be so now
you have benedict cumberbatch who's
doctor strange and he's going to be
peter parker surrogate father figure and
i'm up for that because i like benedict
cumberbatch so i'm that that's that's
fine but again if the premise is he
can't cast like a basic spell to make
people forget that peter parker is in
fact spider-man that does call into
question how successful he's going to be
at fighting
like universe threatening monsters which
is what marvel is all about also i i do
have to say i'm very disappointed that
in this trailer under the academy of
motion picture art and sciences new
rules i'm not sure that this actually
qualifies for any of the academy awards
because peter is white and so has been a
cumberbatch having me critique marvel
films as a dc fanboy is kind of awkward
because i can't remember the last actual
marvel movie i was excited about i
actually do like tom holland as an actor
i think that he's he's been quite good
in some things uh i'm not as big a
zendaya fan i haven't seen her in many
things and what i have seen and i'm not
like thrilled by there are theories that
toby mcguire and andrew garfield might
show up so it'll be all the spider-man's
in one there has to be a moment with the
actual spider-man meme if they do that
right there have to be all three of them
in their spider outfits pointing at each
other if they miss on that that is like
the greatest fail in the history of
spider-man they made a better version of
this film which was called into the
spider-verse which is actually a
terrific spider-man movie into the
spider voice is really good it's like
one of the best superhero movies in the
last 10 years i always feel like
spider-man is sort of like almost minor
league ant-man which is really kind of
putting it down i'm gonna put some dirt
in your eye like paul rudd is is doing
the kind of charming you know funny
routine and spider-man is doing that too
but it also wants to be taken seriously
in a way that that ant-man does not and
i think the best marvel movies are the
ones that really don't take themselves
seriously like at all like i think thor
ragnarok is is one of the best movies
because thor ragnarok is completely
unserious whereas thor two is completely
serious and terrible so final grade out
of five stars i give this trailer three
because it's like perfectly mediocre
right it's passable if it's available
and i have nothing better to do and my
wife insists we will watch this other
than that i'm like am i wildly excited
about this i don't know how you get
wildly excited about this trailer but i
guess some people will be